Here's the answer I came up with.
The actor wants to maximize
the number of burned calories and
he burns 12 calories for
every minute of step-aerobics and
four for every minute of stretching.
He can't spend more
than 40 minutes total.
So I expressed that constraint by
saying that x + y is at most 40.
And expressing that he has to
spend five minutes stretching,
is a little unintuitive because of
the way the inequality is directed here.
But I can do it by saying that
-y is at most -5, like so.
Using the graph and check method of your
high school teacher, gives the optimum
solution as 35 minutes of step
aerobics and 5 minutes of stretching.
Now you probably didn't bother graphing
the polytope as I've done here.
The answer was too obvious.
But why was it so obvious?
Maybe you realized that more exercise
was better, and started thinking about
constraints somewhere along here,
that used up all 40 minutes.
Because step-aerobics
burn more calories,
you realize that you would want to
do as many of them as possible,
pulling you along this constraint,
downward towards this vertex.
Or maybe you realized that just
five minutes of stretching, and
zero minutes of step aerobics
would satisfy the constraints.
And then you decided to
increase the number of minutes
spent on step aerobics,
until you ran into another constraint.
Another case, your intuition led you
to think very much along the lines of
the simplex method,
that we'll see in a little bit.